zerry is out in league of legends and
honestly i think she might be one of the
most interesting champions we've seen
released into the game for years and i'm
not even an 80 carry at the minute
people seem to be either fully running
it down with her or straight up 1v9 but
i genuinely think once the dust settles
and people figure out the builds she
could be a really strong champion oh and
she's also insanely fast and i'm saying
that as a hacker in maine
it's ridiculous
[Music]
hey so you might have noticed that we've
started doing these kind of shorter
don't act me's on the channel we're
really enjoying them and because we can
do more of them now really is the best
time to make sure you're subscribed to
the channel so you don't miss any of
these videos also on this video leave a
like and a comment thank you so league's
158th champion has been out in the game
now for a little under a week which is
just enough time for someone like me to
make some overly confident assessments
and predictions about her for those of
you who haven't had her in one of your
games yet let's quickly run through what
the hell she actually is her passive
gives her a shield whenever she attacks
an enemy shield for a portion of the
damage dealt all shields will grant her
a brief movement speed boost remember
that later her q burst fire turns her
auto attacks into several rounds of
well burst fire it's got a low cooldown
and costs no mana moving and auto
attacking fill up a charge meter which
turns her next auto attack into a burst
ability that deals extra damage to low
hp enemies her w ultra shock laser fires
a pulse which damages the first enemy
hit if it passes through terrain it
widens and extends and can hit multiple
enemies her e spark surge lets her dash
a short distance after which her next
three or two attacks of burst fire can
damage enemies beyond the first spark
surge can be cast over any terrain no
matter how thick it is herald is a
lightning crash which releases an
electric explosion that damages all
nearby enemies hitting a champion grants
overcharge which gives bonus attack
damage on hit damage and a chain
lightning effect on her autos
overcharged stacks can be added and
extended by auto attacks on enemies so
what exactly does all of that mean well
it seems on the surface that zerry is
all about speed she's a super mobile
champion that's supposed to weave in and
out of team fights and be really
difficult to pin down in fact i might go
so far as to say that she might be the
most naturally mobile ad carry that the
game has ever seen it's kind of
ridiculous and if you think i'm
exaggerating well a lot of people saw
this insane clip over the weekend of an
overcharged stacked zerry running rings
around streamer quantum and his friends
now we've sped this up just so you can
see how long it goes on for but as you
can see there is nothing they can do to
stop zerry from breaking their ankles
it's not like she's doing insane damage
to them but she's almost unkillable as
long as they can't get near her
[Applause]
wait
wait
the feedback from the community has been
fairly positive but definitely mixed
doublelift was one streamer who was
quick to write her off
oh
is this a hypercarry i don't think so
i've been trying to hold it in guys but
i don't think this champs very good
biggest weakness that's unexp like hard
to exploit in solo queue is her landing
phase sucks
i think
in competitive what you have to compete
with is people who can lane and get
advantages in lane and snowball from
lane and to be fair that does seem to be
the case based on the limited amount
we've seen of zerry so far i had some
games over the weekend where azeri on my
team would completely run it down during
the laning phase and then hard carry for
the rest of the game she seems a lot
stronger once she can get out of lane
and be creative with the massive amounts
of mobility she has the question is can
she get out of lane without completely
losing the game personally i don't think
you can discount just how strong her
core kit feels i honestly think once
people figure out builds and play styles
for her she could be a really strong
pick i'm a cutie pie has been swearing
by a black cleaver into triforce build
which is pretty unique among 80 carries
at the moment you don't really see that
too often now the crazy thing about
black cleaver is that it gains one of
its stacks every time the champion does
any sort of physical damage well zeri's
auto bursts deal seven separate
instances of physical damage unlike
every other auto attack which
essentially means she can fully stack
her cleaver with one full auto but we're
not gonna get too bogged down in stats
and numbers and builds we'll do that in
the future when she's all figured out
the headline here is zeri is cool
i've loved seeing these insane clips of
her running rings around people yes i
know she looks kind of weak in the
laning phase right now but it's early
days if a busted build for her can
happen it will happen there's going to
be a lot of theory crafting over the
next few weeks and months and sooner or
later someone out there is gonna figure
out the perfect build for her crazy kit
it's just a matter of time
oh my arm has gone dead man
i'm thinking i must have someone boosted
me when i was in my sleep because it
genuinely feels like i got it
my arm's just dead
wondering they're activating the 5g now
[Music]